[Music]
let's go to chicago illinois where
christine joins us christine how can we
help
uh hi john hi ken how are you i'm a
little nervous right now how are you
doing you're doing great yeah what's up
um i have an important question to ask
you in regards to
job and career uh recently just started
a newer job with a really good
pay i'm a health care provider um
working with the under privilege and
making a difference and trying to help
these patients
awesome i'm just i'm just wondering at
this point
with everything that's going on and
trying to
mandate the vaccine for health care
providers
in a lot of places and now
knowing that the federal government has
implemented
in the va system and it might eventually
trickle down to
private uh practices and administrations
and hospital administrations
how do you feel about compromising your
morals for keeping a job so
explain your moral challenges with this
even though we don't know if you're
going to have this mandate come your way
i do like that you're walking through it
but
let's walk it all the way out if they
say you've got to have it for employment
where do you feel like you are
sacrificing your morals
um my religious beliefs
um against the aborted fetal cells that
are being used
either in the process or um
in the actual vaccine they have
available yeah are you leaning
towards compromising or are you leaning
towards saying i can't do this and i
gotta walk
you were leaning one way or another when
you called which way are you leaning
leaning towards not compromising yeah
so you have to prioritize that and i'm
going to tell you something right now if
this is a if this is an integrity thing
or
a very deep religious held spiritual
conviction
i support that but you got to make plans
for it um
you know you you've got to know what you
can live with and what you cannot
and you know i will tell you you need to
seek
seek counsel i've talked to several
people in the last month some on my show
and i've got friends calling me i've got
a friend who called me who's a state
employee in another state
and feels like it's coming down and
asked me the same question and
he has done some homework he went and
sought legal counsel
and i would seek legal counsel
employment specialist
and i would get some counsel maybe two
or three different lawyers and talk to
about about the religious exemption i
will tell you
that it's going to be i think a grab
bag maybe 50 50 as to with some
organizations will
say that's okay some i think will honor
the religious exemption i'm hearing of
that
and uh some will not and it's going to
be a time to choose unfortunately
that's where we stand but you know look
if you plan for this financially
and you've got a plan for if this
happens what would i do
meaning i'm going to walk i'm not going
to take it as long as you've got a plan
then i think you have to honor your
conviction there i'm not going to tell
you to go against your conviction
yeah what i would i i would recommend
two things number one get some
information
when it comes to the vaccine i've never
heard of the particular challenges
you've mentioned
um i've tried to stay pretty close to
the science on it but i i may be wrong
i've never heard that so i'd get i'd get
with some folks and
you're in the medical field so you can
get some good clarity on that the second
thing is
back out of this because this is a hot
hot hot moment
in history back out of this particular
issue
and ask yourself on any ethical issue
they ask you to start overbilling
somebody they ask you to go ahead and
change this number on medicare they ask
you to
fudge your mileage a little bit when
you're taking taking these kids to their
appointments whatever the thing is
i always want you to double down on
doing the right ethical thing
for your heart for your family for your
conscience
and that goes back to what ken was
talking about on any particular issue
that's why that's why the emergency fund
is so important that's why having a
network is so important that's why
having friends in your life
emerge friends of your emergency fund
for life right that's why we do these
things so that when you're faced with
situations
regardless of what they happen to be and
you say i've got to walk out that front
door
that you've got a safety net you've got
a cushion there for you
right yeah so if you feel like this is
coming down what i don't want you to
just catastrophize it
i don't want you to set yourself off
into fight or flight and start solving
problems that aren't there yet
and we can all do that we can ruminate
we can just sit there and
go down internet rabbit hole after
rabbit hole after rabbit hole and make
something
our bodies respond to an issue that
hasn't even happened yet
right and we can always get some more
information and some more information
but
um do start playing and if you have to
make a hard hard choices hard changes
have that safety net there well
christine the decision has already been
made
you've already made the decision and i
respect that right uh i respect men and
women who will take a stand
on principle and in this situation this
is a religious conviction
uh i will tell you to me it's about
freedom
and um you know uh you can do all the
research you want to
and somebody can i mean for every for
every person that says what you say that
hey
i don't like the way the vaccine's been
developed and tested you'll have
somebody who goes
like john well i haven't heard that so i
think he's right
you can go do your homework and make
sure that you're absolutely sure on that
conviction but
do not waver and you know people calling
and i appreciate the call
people saying hey should i do what i
think is right or should i do
what i think is expedient for me
professionally and folks
you know we live in america where we've
not had to make a lot of these choices
all the time
uh and and john's right it doesn't
always have to be a political vaccine
issue because this thing's big this has
become a political football
yeah pure and simple yeah um i don't
care what side you're on that's why i
like to get out of those and say what's
the
when you're faced with what you can't
get out of you you have to say in this
particular situation
she doesn't feel right about this for
the reasons that she
left out now you're right to say go do
your research and make sure that you're
right
because this is a monumental decision
right you don't want to make it right
right
on opinion or theory you've got to know
the facts of the facts that didn't
affect my belief right however you're
also right
this could be as simple as they're
asking you to fudge your expense reports
you know so that they can cook the books
that's equally wrong
and and i would say the same thing if
you feel wrong about that come up with a
plan
that's right you don't have to leave
tomorrow that's right but if you want to
leave tomorrow i'm fine with that too
but you've got to also have a a plan
conviction is important
but we also need to do it in a way
that's wise that's right
and i think that you address that we say
this a lot on the show
nobody makes good decisions when their
heads on fire right when they're
stressed and
when you spend hours and hours and hours
huddled around a water cooler or huddled
down internet rabbit holes man it
those are designed to set your body on
fire well i'm glad you said this because
i'm going to tell you something right
now and you may not agree and that's
fine yeah because you and i can
disagree agreeably we do it all the time
um
but i think you're right i i don't care
what
the biden white house is saying and i
don't care what your company is saying
on some level people have rights
and you can go seek legal counsel and do
your homework but whatever mandates are
coming or
not coming right because we don't know
that this is coming we're hearing all
kinds of stuff of course
the reality is there will be legal
challenges to this stuff of course there
will be which means delays
right so to your point let's not all
freak out
and assume that we got to quit our jobs
because somebody's going to make it take
a vaccine that we don't want to take
yeah so
let's not jump to that conclusion
because i think it's that's not that
simple i've worked for places where i
have been asked to be in situations but
i'm not comfortable with
the beauty was i'd already thought
through my yeah my ethical positions and
so
when i came home and sat down with my
wife and said hey here's where we are
and here's what
it was this it wasn't a oh no what are
we gonna do
those were difficult when i owed six
figures of student loans and we were
paycheck to paycheck to paycheck right i
put myself in a position where
holding my ethical standards was more
difficult yeah but we appreciate the
call christine
it's not easy stuff i love that you're
getting out in front of it don't make a
decision based on fear
make it based on facts